did their
come a time when your friendship with Mr
Dave that became more than that became
romantic and
yes
and at what point in time did your
relationship with Mr dap take in a
romantic turn
after I had moved to Hollywood
and uh he you know switched the buttons
recall what year you moved to Hollywood
yes
um
1994. when you say switch the buttons
can you tell me what you meant by that
um the Friendship went from a purely
platonic friendship
um to a romantic
um
at that point
romantic uh to change that to sexual to
sexual
for how long did your relationship with
Mr Depp remain sexual
several months
anywhere between three and five six
during that period how
else I had seen three or four times a
week
but I'm not looking to pry into into
private details but can you tell me like
where you would see him just give me
some sense of that yeah he would come to
my house or I would go to his house and
both houses in L.A yes about
um 10 minute drive apart from each other
and um at
either when you were at his house
um
where you didn't stay the night or were
you were at his house when you did stay
the night were there other people in the
house who saw you there who were those
people be
um he had an assistant
[Music]
his sister
that's all I can remember now you recall
the name of the assistant
I don't know his name he was referred to
as Pig
he was referred to by who mistake
that at any point that you were either
initially friends and then sexual with
Mr Tapp uh Reeve do you become aware
that he uh
um drink to excess I was always aware
can you explain how you were aware of
that he was drunk all the
most a lot of the time
and that would apply both to when you
were initially friends and then later
when it became sexual yeah
and what was he drunk what what you're
understanding what had he drunk to
become
it was a Red Wine Drinker
okay in addition to alcohol were you
aware at that time that Mr uh Depp was
taking any prescription medication no
um same question Mr Barkin for illegal
substances yeah same question and what
illegal substances
cocaine
marijuana
hallucinogenics
um can you say specifically what those
were I don't really know
he called me and told me he was tripping
um
with respect to any of that
hallucinogenics cocaine or marijuana did
he do any of that in your presence
yes more than once all the time
um when you say all the time how many
times
again in the period that you were both
first friends and sexual then sexual
with Mr Duff do you think you saw I
couldn't even tell you I mean I I just
know he was always drinking
and
or smoking a joint but it would be fair
to say more than at least dozens of
times yeah
over the full course oh yeah
did you ever
um observe
this Barkin uh Mr Depp's Behavior change
when he uh drank more or used more drugs
I did not so he was kind of the same all
the time fair to say
was not the same
he was high
did there come a time
Miss Barkin when Mr Depp
um
acted in a way that was
out of control with you yes
Mr Depp threw a wine bottle across the
room the hotel room on one instance in
Las Vegas while we were shooting fear
and loathing
I guess were you was something about to
happen the fight was going on
between you and Mr Doug no who was the
fight between
Johnny Depp and his friends in the room
the assistant honestly I don't remember
and the bottle that do you remember
seeing here today Miss Parking weather
the bottle was full of wine or empty
I don't
uh sitting here today Miss Parking do
you remember uh whether the bottle hit
you no it did not
um did the bottle hit anyone else no it
did not
approximately how far away from you
was Mr death when he threw the bottle
across the room so maybe by by that
break in the table or a little further
down it was a toss
and
uh
senior day at the bottle had hit you
would it have injured you was it your
understanding back then he was throwing
the bottle at you I don't know why he
threw the bottle
and was it when he threw it was it in
your direction yes were there other
people standing around you yes so he
threw it in your direction at a group of
people yes
whose hotel room was it
his Johnny Depp's
who broke off he did how did it come
about that Mr uh death broke after your
relationship
uh I went to go home uh there was a big
goodbye crying a lot of jealous and
don't do this don't do that and
I never heard from him again after that
and did uh Mr depth not want you to go
back to Los Angeles
there uh yes he didn't want me to go I
was only supposed to be there for two
days I stayed for longer
and you just referenced uh you just used
the word jealous how did that come up
what does he say that indicated to you
that he was jealous he's just a jealous
man controlling where are you going who
are you going with what what did you do
last night I had a scratch on my back
once that got him very very angry
because he insisted it came from me
having sex with a person who wasn't him
during the time that you were in a
sexual relationship uh with Mr dapp
was it common for him to say things to
you about being controlling to use your
words or being jealous of you
yeah very common
and uh when in these instances when Mr
Depp
became jealous or controlling did he
also become angry yeah
and demanding
all right ladies and gentlemen is going
to take your afternoon recess please do
not discuss the case and do not do any
outside research okay